[Music]
hey and welcome to et live I'm Sophie
Scholl 8c Morgan Wallen joins us today
in the studio welcome thank you for
being here for having me how you doing
good how are you good
busy and good yes this is a huge week
for you release week congratulations
thank you yeah it's a feels like it's
been a long time coming it has right so
last time I saw you was in October in
Nashville we did an episode a certified
country together I feel like so much has
changed even since then uptown has gone
crazy yeah I guess up/down was kind of
just getting started last time we talked
you know so to see the response and how
everybody is kind of digging it is it's
really cool let's talk about the album
to start it is coming out this Friday
it's called if I know me yeah tell me a
little bit about what the album title
means and what fans can expect
yeah yeah well the album is kind of just
a complete journey for me these past
three years you know I moved to
Nashville in 2015 and there's some songs
on there from from 2015 and there's some
songs on there that we literally
finished the day that the album was had
to be done so it's a full you know a
representation of me these last few
years and hopefully of my whole life you
know and originally I was gonna name the
album something like off the wall that
had nothing to do with any of the songs
but then we wrote if I know me kind of
towards the end of the process and it
just made a whole lot of sense you know
like if I know me then here's what
here's what you get so it just made a
lot of sense very cool so a long time
coming very excited for you and the song
is just absolutely blowing up up down
with FGL mm-hmm I when I interviewed you
it was kind of just starting I
interviewed the FGL guys about it as
well and asked them kind of why they
wanted to get involved with the song and
they said simply put it was a smash yeah
those boys man they've been they've been
super good to me to come in you know
treating me like a little brother
throughout this whole throughout the
whole process since I've met him really
so I'm glad their own song with me now
is it crazy to you to kind of see the
response that it's gotten and yeah I
mean you know when we first recorded the
song I think we all had a feeling that
it was a special song but
you don't ever know for a fact you know
so to see that people are love it as
much as we did in the beginning is super
cool tell me about how your relationship
has evolved with those guys yeah you
know I think we we met I whenever I
first moved to Nashville I started
running around with a lot of the same
people that they are in business with
you know so we kind of just met first
and hit it off a little bit and well we
all like to write songs so let's try and
write songs so we started doing that and
then they you know they asked me to go
out with some shows last year with them
played some shows with them last year
and then you know I think we're just i
consider them like some of my best
friends so it's it's you know kind of
just progressed slowly throughout years
and you guys have been writing together
as well right yeah yeah we wrote the
song as Jason Aldean single right now
you make it easy together and obviously
really proud of that also I love that so
much and I was so excited when I saw
that you wrote it I had no idea it just
kind of popped up one day I was like oh
my gosh
tell me the story behind that song yeah
we were we were out on the road I don't
remember where we were at but it's one
of those shows that they had asked me to
come out and play with them and we were
they have a writers bus also so like
there's a bus that we get up there and
we write songs on and that day we we
brought you make it easy meet Tyler
Brian and the guy named Jordan Smith was
it inspired by Tyler's wife I think I
read yeah yeah yeah he said something
about how you know our lifestyle and
just the way that we have to do things
it's not necessarily the easiest for a
relationship you know it's kind of hard
it's kind of stressful and he said that
morning he told Haley that she made it
easy so we were all like let's write
that Matt so we did and it turned out to
be a special song and I think I think we
all knew it as special but apparently
the minute Jason Aldean heard it he was
just kind of like yeah there's gonna be
my first single so go alright Congrats
are there any other songs coming down
the pipeline that you can tease like I'm
assuming you guys have written more that
we haven't heard yeah well they're
they're really busy now I'm pretty busy
there's been a couple that we've wrote
on
exactly I don't know all their plans yet
but I've got I've got one at least one
or maybe two on their new album so very
cool
yeah that's awesome I want to get to
some fan questions and comments coming
in keep them coming you guys
I will ask as many as we can get to
Jessica wants to know who are your
musical inspirations
yeah well country wise Eric Church is
one of the main reasons that I've seen
country music I didn't necessarily grow
up on country music though it was always
somewhat a part of my life but I grew up
more on like Lynyrd Skynyrd Bad Company
Led Zeppelin more of the classic rock
type of things but the minute that I
heard Eric Church it kind of just hit me
in a way that no music ever had so I
consider him probably my biggest
influence overall he's incredible yeah
shout out to Ashley she says love up
down such a fun song do you ever get
sick of your songs no I mean like when I
first got started out I guess not the
quality of songs that I you know I was
just learning how to write like I still
I've only been performing for about four
years or something like that so I still
feel like I'm growing and learning but
no now I have you know we the most the
longest we have to play is 60 75 minutes
I feel like I have a good catalog of
songs that I actually enjoy singing all
of them and I enjoy every night so and
correct me if I'm wrong isn't it a
compliment if someone tells you your
song is overplayed yeah please play more
can't blather move yeah yeah Katie wants
to know any dream collaborations yeah I
mean Eric Church obviously and I'm also
a huge fan of post Malone these days so
and I've been I've actually been write
one of the song the title track to my to
my album I actually wrote with one of
his producers so oh cool it's such a
small world yeah he he kind of took a
step out and and has been coming to
Nashville and we we got hooked up just
because he was down there and I guess he
was talking to my publisher we kind of
hit it off so we've been writing a few
songs together and I love his Bob so who
knows maybe as possible very cool we got
to talk about stagecoach also coming up
this weekend how excited are you yeah
very excited I it's one of those
festivals that you always hear about you
know it's
kind of got a little mystique to it or
whatever and for it's my first time
playing it and a lot of firsts for me
this week so they were looking forward
to it have you ever been to stagecoach
before this will be your first I'm never
been to like a festival as a fan ever in
my life so Wow
I would like to go to something like
that just as a fan one time if I ever if
I ever get the time where do you do
Coachella you think yeah yeah yeah yeah
I figured I don't know it might not be
good to me but Brian just sending the
question what artists in a different
genre would you want to work with I know
you just said post
that's hard to say I really like Khalid
I've been listening to a lot of his
stuff too so if I had to pick okay back
to stage coach for a minute obviously
the FGL guys are headlining one of the
nights are you playing the same day that
they are or is it a different day yeah
okay cool so can we expect you guys to
jump onstage together I honestly don't
know yeah if we do it'll be just as much
a surprise to me does it everybody yes
but I hope so does that stuff come
together at the last minute very very
much so yes is there anyone else you're
really excited to see at the festival
I'm not sure who's playing the days I'm
playing but I know that there's a guy
named Jason Isbell he's playing the next
day I wish I could I wish I could stay
because he's a he's one of my favorite
songwriters he's kind of like a folky
kind of guy I don't know if you're
familiar with him but yeah I wish I
could see him I see a couple more
questions coming in Erik wants to know
would you ever do a reality show or
Dancing with the Stars obviously Morgan
comes from the voice you guys so you did
do the reality Dancing with the Stars I
don't know I'm not a good dancer at all
I'm gonna have to take like years of
lessons before I even just even consider
stepping out on there cuz I don't know I
make a fool of myself
yeah I think they teach people right
isn't that the point of it I mean yeah
but I don't know there's there's so much
you can do you know are you
watching the voice do you keep up on
that at all I don't I don't do a whole
lot of watching the TV honestly if I if
I watch anything it's sports and a
little bit of Netflix you know but
mostly I really I'm a huge sports fan so
I always I always watch that okay I love
this username from YouTube sweet and
sassy southern belle hey girl hi Morgan
in the song the way I talk
I heard the shout out to the voles where
are you from yeah yeah I'm from
Knoxville Tennessee that's that's what I
consider my hometown so I've got a
couple of songs with some with some
references to to Knoxville and to
Tennessee so yeah very good Cassie wants
to know how has your life changed since
having a hit single you know it's it's a
lot busier everything is you don't I
guess you don't really realize how when
things take off how much different it is
unless you really take a step back you
know cuz you're always so focused on
what's next and you know writing the
next song or what's the next single and
all that kind of stuff but it's a it's
been really cool to see you know when we
go when we go play at venues especially
with fans it's awesome to see that
they're really buying into what we're
doing as a project and as an artist and
not just with not just with my singles
but just as a whole project and know
that they really care so I'm starting to
see that difference for sure Erin says
do you still talk to your voice coach no
I haven't really got to to talk to any
of the people from the voice so I think
I kind of got I was off the show before
we really got into kind of any intimate
relationships or anything like that I
kind of got out of a at a time before
that started happening so I'm not mad
about it yeah yeah that makes sense now
let's talk a little bit about the summer
that you have coming up so you're
playing stagecoach this weekend so check
that out guys if you don't already have
tickets it'll be so much fun yeah and
then this summer you're going to be
joining with Brian on tours all right
Brian yeah May 31st will be our first
show with with Luke and we're going up
until like September 2nd I believe so 30
or 40 shows with Luke which is crazy you
know we get to play like Dodger Stadium
Fenway Wrigley that's huge
as a sports guy that's kind of playing
baseball and always imagined and playing
baseball in those places so now getting
to play music and in those places is
honestly even cooler to me that's so fun
and how all do you know Luke not not
super well we've hung out a couple times
yeah yeah yeah I I'm looking forward to
we played a festival the other day
together and I didn't see him all day
but he he was playing in our side stage
and he came over and between a song and
like gave me a hug and everything I can
I'm really looking forward forward to it
now I'm super grateful that he asked me
out absolutely he is just one of the
nicest guys to I think oh this is a
million dollar question Sarah wants to
know who do you like better Luke Bryan
or Blake Shelton Luke Bryan I had
nothing to gets like that I don't know
like that well but yeah if I had to pick
right now for sure Luke my solid answer
thank you so much for being here Morgan
see you again
you guys should pick up this album this
Friday check them out at stagecoach and
where else can they find you on social
media yeah Morgan wongkom and then my
Instagram and my Twitter are Morgan see
wallet that's that's pretty much it
perfect and then if you want to see more
with Morgan we do have an episode of
certified country up with him and the
FGL guys you can go to certified country
at Facebook watch thank you guys so much
for watching I'm Sophia Lacey and until
next time we'll see you later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]